Life can be heavy, especially if you try to carry it all at once.
Part of growing up and moving into new chapters of your life is about catch and release.
What I mean by that is knowing what things to keep and what things to release.
You can't carry all things.
Decide what is yours to hold and let the rest go.
Oftentimes, the good things in your life are lighter anyway, so there's more room for them.
Secondly, learn to live alongside cringe.
No matter how hard you try to avoid being cringe,...
...you will look back on your life and cringe retrospectively..
Cringe is unavoidable over a lifetime.
Even the term "cringe" might someday be deemed cringe.
Never be ashamed of trying.
Effortlessness is a myth.
The people who wanted it the least were the ones I wanted to date...
...and be friends with in high school.
The people who want it the most are the people I now hire to work for my company.
Every choice you make leads to the next choice which leads to the next.
And I know it's hard to know which path to take.
There will be times in life where you need to stand up for yourself.
Sometimes, the right thing to do is to throw out the old schools of thought...
...in the name of progress and reform.
Sometimes, the right thing to do is to sit and listen...
...to the wisdom of those who have come before us.
I leave you with this:...
We are led by our gut instincts, our intuition,...
...our desires and fears, our scars and our dreams.
Anyway, hard things will happen to us, we will recover.
We will learn from it.
We will grow more resilient because of it.
And as long as we are fortunate enough to be breathing,...
...we will breathe in, breathe through, breathe deep, breathe out.
And I am a doctor now, so I know how breathing works.